what's up guys special shout out to our
sponsor blue man hair care products as
you know we've been using blue man for
past maybe two months and guys me
personally using it every day because I
want to actually use the stuff that we
have on the channel I don't want to just
bring something on if I don't use it and
or if Marty doesn't use it you know what
I'm saying something that we can't
actively use and put to the test but so
far guys I've been using blue man every
single time I do my hair every single
show since the first time they sent me
something 100 I approve and I know about
70 of dudes aren't actively putting pair
care products I understand but the 30
that makes up a lot of the world man and
that's why there are hair care products
for men so I used to just do the whole
water and hairspray and guys to be
honest for me to you if from experience
it just dries my hair I got hella bad
dandruff and it's it's lame I look dirty
all right so I've been using blue man I
say for the past two months and I can
notice the difference immediately it's
just it really is help it's not LA Gear
times remember that La stuff where it's
like see-through red yellow green do you
ever have those looks yeah L.A looks
everything it it's not like that guys
it's not if this is just the adult
version of hair care I feel they have
really cool packaging everything about
it is dope I love it I've used it
personally every single episode but if
you do want to check it out guys go to
www.blueman.com that's
b-l-u-m-a-a-n.com forward slash Yola
that is our link or you can use code
Yola at checkout and that code will get
you 10 off and as always if you don't
want to type this all in the link in
this description all of our videos the
link in description has blue man's link
goes directly through it just remember
use code Yola for 10 off so as always
guys thank you so much for using the
code thank you for supporting the people
that support us we appreciate you
foreign
you guys asked so much the day has
finally come here it is introducing dope
as usual merch we have shirts in black
and white sizes small through 3x we have
sweaters we have shorts and beanies we
have the shirt in white or black we have
the hoodie with the back print and the
front print we have shorts and beanies
so if you want to check it out it's dope
as usual dot store or click the link in
the description of the video
what's up everybody I am Thomas
dopasiola whatever you want to call me
welcome back to another episode of the
dope as usual podcast today we are
talking to a legendary person and as you
can see from the title as you can see
from the thumbnail you already know who
it is
um
what is there really to say like Marty I
know this is the intro but come on man
some legendary shirts this is [ __ ]
awesome all right my father-in-law's
freaking the [ __ ] already
this is [ __ ] awesome guys I'm so damn
happy to announce that this is the Tommy
Chong episode
filmmaker comedian musician
cannabis producer happiness producer
Tommy Chong man like every like I told
you I'm excited I've talked to him once
before I filmed with him and it was
so [ __ ] fun so thank you guys so much
for being here we really appreciate it
we're doing this intro because obviously
got away from us again and I we just
started talking and I even told him like
yo okay hold on let's do an intro and
then and then we just kept going on them
tangents and just never stopped the
entire episode it just never stopped so
guys uh this is the intro this is the
Tommy Chong episode we hope you guys
enjoy it I'm very very excited also guys
big announcement we just hit 100
000 subscribers on YouTube
we hit 100K guys thank you so it's been
a few months since we started but to see
a hundred thousand on there it's very
very cool hundred thousand friends a
hundred thousand homies a hundred
thousand people having fun hanging out
with Marty and I every week so thank you
guys so much from us to you we
appreciate you guys also we hit a what
was it a million watch time a million
views
combined in this month which is huge for
us so thank you guys so much for
supporting for watching Spotify for
Apple podcast everything thank you guys
so much this is awesome so let's get
into it I know we don't get too too far
but we want to say thank you 100 000 is
really big to us but let's get back to
why we're all here why we're so damn
excited and why I'm smiling like this
guys this is the Tommy Chong episode
let's get to it you can
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
well sorry we just started getting
conversation let's let's start let's
start this real quick because you don't
know he's got a water there or no oh
yeah you have a water right here and you
have a joint lighter ashtray if you want
to smoke oh I see that that you got one
or I'll take care okay um is this shot
you're good
um also so I'm gonna just let the intro
he's let the little 10 second song play
I'll do the intro and then we'll start
okay cool cool and you don't have to
wear the headphones it's up to you I
just I can hear myself oh you like the
look yeah I know I can hear it that
Howard Stern look you see I was watching
the horse I haven't seen him for years
he's up on a like a pedestal now oh at
the studio yeah
and they speak the whole thing and then
he's got the the guests are way down
they're like 40 feet out yeah
it's CR it's like some night and King
table stuff yeah yeah like he's he's
elevated he's like yeah he's on the
throne he's definitely it's almost like
King of Kings that's exactly well I mean
for when it comes to radio podcasts and
who else is the biggest person on the
planet Howard Stern Howard Stern is the
biggest and you know how we gotta start
Cheech and Chong records really
listening to Cheech and Chong
what do you mean that's how he was
inspired to do his thing well inspired
him yeah oh really you know how we we
went crazy with our bits with our record
bits and that you know we did all we did
plot commercials you know way way before
you know Acapulco Gold and then we'd
have these crazy uh horrendous revolver
uh we're in the studio of horrendous
revolver that would take off on her
Geraldo Rivera we just talked about it
it's crazy that you say that he was
inspired by that because I've been doing
this for the podcasting only a few
months but we've been making content
doing all this for 10 years sure and
I've made I can't tell you how many
Cheech and Chong skits I've made
marching chunk videos and just little
skits with weed and nugs with a bandana
on and this over I mean that's what I've
been doing for 10 years no I I
when teaching I broke up
uh what year was it Howard uh uh I think
it was 84.
around there 80s 182 83. we were doing a
movie a year or every other year we did
a movie and then the last movie was of
course again brothers that we actually
and that was in the 80s that was 81 or
two something like that but by the time
we added it it was around 84 I think it
took three years for editing
well you know yeah I didn't get ready oh
yeah yeah oh because you I mean you're
doing feature films yeah back when you
had to clip the stuff together correct
you
know movies take a few years yeah each
one but uh after when cheats and I broke
up
uh Howard I went on Howard Stern and we
had a thing uh we're gonna find the new
Cheech oh wow and so uh we were
advertising and we had we had uh
auditions at the Laugh Factory in LA
and we never got one Mexican
we got it's old ladies jugglers we got
impersonations any anything any excuse
to get on stage oh I see like a like a
performance before the Stars before
dancing all the nut cases come on and
then I realized well that's what Cheech
and Chong were 100 yeah
extra testicle that right there is
ridiculous man I saw that when I was
about five years old I go whoa these
guys are crazy he's not Burt Reynolds
that's not Birdman that's what I thought
that is not Burt Reynolds mom
that movie that movie we broke every
rule
now you know well you can get away with
any of that
that movie's like a poster of what
you're not supposed to do oh the outer
space I know we can't even say it I
can't even say the skit name but the
outer space one when I was a kid was
great I just didn't understand you know
when you're a child and you're yeah
you're watching something like that guy
is in that movie but I thought he was
that man how was he two different
because you think that that's really
them you know when you're okay like
that's wait always an actor that's not
Mr birds
and Mr Dolly Mrs Dolly Parton I just
remember thinking these adults think
that's Dolly Parton I'm because I'm done
I just didn't understand as a kid
um so that was the last movie you filmed
you said well together together you know
and then Cheech went on to do uh born in
East L.A oh yes and then that was that
was the end of us that really but just a
mutual just no too long no I I I no what
happened it was Mutual that the the
cheeched didn't like I got more power
you know I was the director I I wrote
all the movies anyway yeah I knew that
and and then I and I directed all the
movies I didn't know you directed them
yeah because uh if you're making up you
should you know
uh you have to direct people what to do
yes you know direct okay we're going to
come in here the camera is going to hear
you know that kind of thing you know
we'll do a bit you do this you say this
I'll do that you know and so uh chich
got uh yeah his nose got out of joint
you know oh really and so then he uh he
he's going to write his own movie you
know what she did you know born in East
L.A and when we did he did the tune
first you know that was under the Cheech
and Chong Banner you know Cheech and
Chong a dead uh uh born in East L.A but
born in East L.A was a takeoff of uh of
uh what's his name uh Bruce Springsteen
oh okay born in America in the USA Born
in the USA yeah see but chicha's born in
East L.A got more popular
but he never wrote a pardon him for me
oh there was no part for me to play
really think about it you know there's
there was no room for me to play and and
then the record itself he put a he had a
little place where I play a cop
you know well that my character's Chong
you know and Chong is not a cop anything
but yeah and I'm not going to play a cop
yeah
you know because I didn't you know I I I
spent my whole life getting this
character this Tommy Chong character and
I wasn't gonna you know lose it just to
be on screen yeah you know so I I made
sure I stayed true to my character and
when when Cheech wrote uh we we had this
argument just recently because we did a
documentary We were finishing up a
documentary and so in the car in the
documentary we're arguing about born in
East L.A I don't know if they'll show it
on screen or not but that was the
problem that I had you know and also the
I had a problem with see Up in Smoke we
got deported and Up in Smoke yeah no
Cheech we were gonna uh
right we're we're trying to write a
movie after
we get sort of got back together again
you know and uh
and uh what the what what what's that
movie about the cops uh
highway patrolman or the dumb I I forget
Super Troopers yep yeah yeah those guys
wanted to do a movie Broken Lizard And
and I and I broke a lizard so I said uh
something about uh well they want about
Eastdale they you know being deported
and I said well
we got deported in uh in uh Up in Smoke
and Cheech argued he said wait what are
you talking about exactly what happened
argued he said we never got deported in
Up Up in Smoke what are you talking
about
I had that I had that expression did you
have to go for a second wait did we
no you did
you did that was the expression
what
because to me but see again I wrote that
part where we get deported it's a pretty
vital part of the movie
I you would think but see he he directed
born in East L.A so what he was thinking
that we never got deported like the kid
got deported by a mistake you know like
a real departure it was a funny one it
was a funny one where where it was like
hey hey uh Uncle Louie yeah yeah we got
deported man you know yeah where are you
oh oh oh you want us to drive a car back
oh no problem
it was that quick
and so when when she you know did that a
boy because it was a real kid that got
deported by mistake
and uh and she definitely wanted to uh
to rip on that now my version would have
been
Cheech and Chong are heroes we either go
get the Kid
smuggle him back you know some some some
where where we're together you know but
uh he he was he was really tired of me
uh telling him what to do he did not
want to hear it he didn't want to hear
my voice ever again
so I'm assuming wait how did you guys
exactly meet the first day you ever met
was it
well again you know what I found out I I
do a lot of cameos now and I and I tell
people
the
truth
is so powerful
because it doesn't change yes you can
enlarge it you can make it bigger than
but it's the truth the truth was teach
was up in Canada
dodging the draft getting out of the
draft the he was in school and all of a
sudden
his name appeared on the draft thing he
was going to get drafted into the
Vietnam War and he's not a fighter and
his dad was an ex sailor in the second
world war and his dad was uh a sergeant
at the LAPD and I did not know that at
all oh yeah chicha's uh Oscar Oscar is
well known
and so Chief was really raised in a very
strict uh environment although the and
and so
he had a choice you know he would he
would have been dead and so he's a
Mexican going to the Vietnam War so he
he took off he he joined you know that
whole anti-war movement burned his draft
card and left uh for Calgary now the the
Serendipity thing was that he moved
right
where I was raised right to the same
neighborhood and he met this kid said I
grew up with in in school and she's not
teach so what he did he left La went up
to to work with a world-renowned Potter
Cheech was a a part like Pottery yeah
Pottery Mexican Potter I know never
heard of that
but anyway he was up there working with
the world-renowned Potter uh dranchuk
was his name and uh and he was up there
for about a year and then he went to
Banff uh with some friends and he broke
his leg compound fracture in his uh I
think his right leg and so he was on
crutches laid up and and then uh he
lived in Calgary and Banff and then
Calgary and then or pritas Alberta and
then he uh ended up in Vancouver
I I think he hitchhiked the banker I'm
not sure the whole stories but he was
always entertaining and always funny and
so then I was with Motown and then I got
fired from Motown because I Motown
records Motown records yeah you used to
work there I'm a guitar player
songwriter I I knew but you were saying
you got fired from like a band you were
there yeah yeah okay yeah what happened
I was with Motown got fired Motown took
Bobby Taylor the singer I ended up
playing it like a backup band for Chris
Clark then I had to get a green card
yeah I'm Canadian I got deported from uh
uh from the states to Windsor Ontario I
got deported across self in
self-deportation it's called and so I
had to get a green card I had to miss a
gig uh I was with Chris Clark and had to
miss a gig to do the do the meeting you
know the Green Card meeting and the road
manager of Motown didn't know what a
green car was and he told me if I miss a
gig I'm fired and so I missed the gig I
got fired then Barry Gordy found out
about it called me up said oh you're not
fired and I said yeah I think I I'm
gonna stay fine very good he's the owner
of the hotel records correct yeah and
Barry was a good friend you know and he
really appreciated and so Barry gave me
a nice uh severance pay and so then I
went back to first I stopped in La first
I wanted just to be a songwriter you
know which I am now by the way so I've
seen it I've been here I've been to your
live shows yeah so so I'm more and now I
do I'm doing poetry and so uh but anyway
I I was going to become a songwriter and
then the the nightclubs that we own the
family-owned nightclubs in Vancouver
needed my attention so I went back and I
turned we had a strip club uh was one of
our clubs I used to run a strip club too
yeah oh yeah we we owned an after-hours
Club
by the way the guy that bought the
building had an empty Steakhouse
approached me why don't you put a club
in there with the band you know and pay
rent when you start making it we we did
that with the After Hours club we got so
successful another club owner that was
had a dinner Club he comes up do you
want another club we said sure So we
turned the dinner Club into a strip club
Vancouver's first strip club the first
one the first one yeah at first we had
to do body painting and pasties
and then and so what I did I came back
without a band now I I I'm free I don't
have any you know I don't have a band to
carry around and so I started working at
the strip club in the light Booth
watching the show and then I realized
you know this would make a good
improvisational
club and so I changed the strip club
with but I used the girls as actresses
and and I use the MC and the singers as
actors and then the MC quit because uh
it's kind of funny his name was tap's
hair it's a black guy that tap dancer
and the reason uh and he would just come
out and here's uh Sophia and here's
Maureen and here's so and so and so when
I change it to a to a uh improvisational
Club the the scene was it was a pajama
party after the strip club and so the
girls would show up in their street
clothes and Taps harrises show up for
the party and then say hey why do they
call you taps and yeah I'm a tap dancer
well let me see something so Taps did a
tap dance you know did a show and he was
so good
that the audience clapped so hard they
needed an encore and so he did The
Encore and then he quit right after that
it was too too hard to work he was an
old guy man and that quit after
everybody gave him a standing away [ __ ]
I go out all right you went out on top
he quit he quit and and so I went to the
doorman who was a very funny guy you
know funny face everything and I said
Dave was his name Dave I said do you
want to take over a tap's place
and Dave said to me he's well I'll do it
if you do it
and all of a sudden I'm on stage and I
couldn't say no it's the first time and
so I said okay so now instead of
directing I'm acting
and I loved it I I took to it right away
and Dave he took to it right away and so
we had a real good comedy thing then we
had another straight guy Rick lens
because we needed a straight guy we we
had we had the long hair and Rick Lance
had the short hair and so he could play
a cop he could play a businessman he
could play all these different
characters and so but his wife Rick was
a legitimate actor you know stage actor
and so we got so popular because you
know no one ever saw uh strippers act
you know and when they took her up their
clothes it would be their street clothes
you know and so when we do do a skit
where they take off their clothes it was
really sexy you know wasn't that you
know that that thing what year is this
huh what year is this uh 68.
1968 and and so uh and then we went into
69 because we spent 68 the summer or the
Christmas 69 it was in the strip club
and and I would go down periodically
because I was married I had two two kids
in L.A
and uh and I had my girlfriend now my
wife working as a waitress in in the
strip club oh wow and so I'd go in
between
uh cities you know Vancouver and then LA
and so Christmas time I'd flew I flew
down to LA and then I went and caught
the committee you know the improv group
in LA in Hollywood and I I I would
see the bits memorize what I could you
know and then I'd go back and teach our
our people so you're taking the class to
teach improv class to your guys yeah
yeah cool and so I I but anyway the the
the wife of the straight actor Rick uh
we got so popular we hit the front page
of the uh Vancouver Sun and it's a
picture of Rick lands with the strippers
on either side with their titties in his
ear they printed that oh yeah well you
know I mean they weren't bare titties
you know oh okay okay they had the bras
on you know but they're they're they're
obviously nice uh titties
and Rick Lindsay's wife you know she was
like a Jehovah Witness or something
straight you know she marched Rick out
of that club so fast and so I needed a
straight back oh that was the last time
he ever went and so he got tracked out
forever yeah and so so this mutual
friend who was a uh you know a big fan
of the show he he came up to me he's I
know the perfect guy for you he's this
little oh you got to meet him and so
then I went I met this Richard Marin
wow and uh Richard it was in a Mexican
we don't no one knew what he was short
hair the clean shaven Richard
and when he joined the group he came
down he saw our act and he liked it he
joined the group
and uh and at first he just watched and
then he kind of memorized everything you
know and and then he would have had a
like a he was a writer and he would do
the odd bit you know but uh
but we got so successful that we almost
went broke in the club
ow
because you weren't doing strip clubs
the strip club we'd get 20 drunks that
would throw their money around you know
hey you know just throw their money
we now we got a theater crowd sipped
their wine and Count Their change
there was no money happening and they
pay it and I wasn't smart enough to
charge a church at the door yeah you
know I never thought of it I I never
ever looked at the financial thing I was
always on stage
so anyway my brother said come up to me
he would run the club threw the bills in
front of my face and says we got to go
back to the bikers you know
and so we did
I think the next week and so Cheech and
I were the only ones that wanted to keep
going Richard and I and so Richard and I
put a band together
uh you because I'm a Blues singer you
know a blues guitar player and and
uh Richard's the singer
but we we went and we entered the battle
of the bands in Vancouver so you really
did do a battle of the bands oh we did a
band we did it we had a band but they
never played one note
Richard and I went out and did 45
minutes of Comedy which we've been doing
in the strip club
see in the strip club we used to do two
shows two one hour shows and you know
the first star and then we would take
questions from the answer requests from
the audience oh this is like an improv
live show you guys it was total improv
and so then the uh that crowd would
leave
and then we come up and do a second show
with a new audience and so that's how we
built our rep repertoire anyway uh so
when we before we played music teaching
that we're going to do a little comedy
we never played one note we were just
totally into comedy because we weren't
into music you know other than just me
playing the guitar and singing and so
the band the band was funny he goes
when's our next gig boss oh they never
even played they never played at all so
that night we're driving home and it was
Richard and Chong so we're trying to
think of a name
and I said uh to change don't you have a
nickname he said yeah Cheech
and so it was nice Cheech and Chong that
was the first time I heard the word
Cheech
and it was Cheech and Chong and I didn't
I still didn't know at the time I didn't
know he was Mexican because in Canada
there are very few Mexicans yeah you
don't hear a Mexican there is one
football player uh and that was the only
guy we knew you know and uh weren't into
Mexican food or anything like that until
I met Cheech and so then now because
Cheech was a fugitive
oh that's right we have to sneak into
L.A so it's Sneaky sneak it from
from Canada
Cheech gets a friend of his ID a white
guy's ID
what name everything showed him the idea
at the border boom Going In how ironic
and we're Mexican into America from from
Canada no one has no one thought about
it and he's an American
I'm the guy
that I'm a Canadian and I I walk in like
no problem and and so so then when you
hit LA and uh
we start looking for gigs you know any
and we started working mostly black
clubs because it would hire me you know
from my experience with Bobby Taylor and
the vancouvers yeah I had an in with all
the black clubs and so when they find
out I'm doing comedy they loved it
because uh you know that was their but
they always had a comedian and a dancer
and then dancing you know with the band
and so we did that for about a year but
the first gig we did
teach almost didn't make it
teach when he got back to LA he hooked
up with his old buddies you know he was
in Big Bear
all the mountains yeah and I was uh and
I was getting us a gig in in L.A at the
red fox Club Red Fox I only had a club
oh he had one for a while on La Cienega
wow and so um
anyway she made it back at first he was
going well you know I'm here and I said
Cheech the only reason we're here is to
start working yeah so he he made it back
and we went on at the red fox club for
the first time in LA
and uh it's a historical moment man oh
yeah is that club still there no no no
who knows God this is God in fact we
were announced uh Norma uh Norma Miller
a black comedian a dancer uh she
couldn't pronounce her name so she
called this geek and gank
and here they are geek and gank did you
guys get paid for that one the first the
first thing you ever did we never got
paid for so he's just doing because he
loved it we did it it was open mic and
so we went on but what we did do uh we
hooked up with Lenny Bruce oh all his uh
Entourage then he had died a couple of
years earlier and the and they were like
cruising the comedy clubs you know
because they used to be with Lenny every
day and now now but Lenny's uh ex
father-in-law Tony vascara another uh
beautiful uh Chicano uh he came up to me
and he gave me the best compliment
he said you know I'm uh Tony uh vascara
you know my father-in-law was
Lenny Bruce and I was married to Sally
Mara's mother actually he was Lenny's
father whoa and he was married to Sally
Lenny's mother but anyway Tony
he said to me he said you're the closest
to Lenny Bruce that I've ever seen
and first show he and he tells you that
yeah and so then Tony first of all he he
wanted to be our manager but he was
Broker Than we were
and he and he had a bit of a uh
heroinette uh problem you know a bit
that's bad yeah any bit of that is but
he but he he stayed for a long time he
hung around he saw us make it and he was
there he was like our coach
when we're we we go do these different
clubs you know because we worked a good
year we're going at PJs we worked the
Smothers Brothers had a club and uh in
Huntington Beach it was a Rowdy Beer
Club that the Smothers Brothers couldn't
work who's mother brother what's that
Smothers Brothers were a comedy team
from the 60s on TV there used to be a
lot of Comedy like Duos you're saying no
that was the neighborhood the comedy duo
the Tom and uh
what's his name Tom anyways the Smothers
Brothers they're very famous everybody a
world renowned and I just read a real
funny thing about there was a singer
called
Nielsen
uh he did a song called uh people
talking about me and I can't hear a word
they're saying miracles of my mind that
was uh Nielsen Nielsen at the end of his
life in his career he was a drunk and a
Rowdy drunk teamed up with John Lennon
when John Lennon was uh in between Yoko
and uh and miling you know the Chinese
and he was like in his wild times he was
him and Nielsen they went to the
troubadour
when the Smothers Brothers were trying
to come back because some others
Brothers had their own TV show then they
were on sunny and Cher they were so big
a variety show they had variety of shows
so then they're making their big
comeback at the Troubadour and their
first night there they run into John
Lennon and Nielsen and they're drunk and
they heckled them literally heckled them
off the stage they stopped their
comeback
because John Lennon preaching positivity
was like you you can suck
she would I'd walk off stage too like am
I doing that bad John Lennon tackling me
I'm out again when you get John Lennon
heckling you the nicest man and Nielsen
Nielsen was a was his claim Nielsen's
claim to fame was that he never worked
live
no they did he was a songwriter only
never worked live and yet he had the
best voice his voice was so good that
Paul McCartney calls him personally hey
Nielsen this is Paul McCartney I just
want to say use a great singer and
phenomenal songwriter wow he wrote one
is the only number yes uh but uh I
didn't know he wrote that he wrote that
Nielsen oh he wrote a ton of it's wild
to think of how many people performers
write other performers songs yes yeah
it's unbelievable yeah and that was new
but when I heard that when I I saw the
documentary it's on uh
to be or some kind of TV oh
um I just saw it I just saw the little
the new streaming platform yeah yeah so
so Nielsen check it out man it's funny
and my my brother-in-law with my first
wife he was a drummer of Three Dog Night
oh the the people that sang the song
yeah and so he's in the documentary
that's why random your ex-brother-in-law
used to be in Three Dog Night yeah yeah
no I'm I'm connected in so many ways
that's a very random connection
my whole life is has been like that you
know do you think that helped you shape
to what you wanted to do or do you think
it just all happened randomly and just
kept going I'm I'm part of it I'm just
part of this whole thing well like the
pot
there's a good example you know because
when we did Up in Smoke I mean pot was
so illegal you know there are people
doing life in prison right now still
that we're there yeah when watching that
movie yeah yeah and so uh
yeah so you know uh Tommy Chong and
Cheech and Chong Cheech and Chong man
around the world
I have a question
if you were doing all that back then I
mean even now people do have social
media like hey don't put that on the
internet you might get in trouble cop
sees you reckon did you have a hard time
going through checkpoints and going to
certain places because who you were are
you kidding no stop getting searched we
had all that [ __ ] and we would get
caught I would get caught you still
bring the weed I used to smuggle my weed
in my guitar case because uh you know
when Cheech and I split up I started
doing a solo act and then I'd I'd bring
my guitar and and we'd rent a knap uh
fire you know somewhere
but I always carried my smoke and my
guitar case above my head and so when
the dog searched anything they could
never find it it was always up there
and so except one time I forgot I had a
pipe in my pocket
and the dog next thing you know I got a
dog on my balls you know he's got his
nose right in there oh it's a friendly
pup and so they so they they
immigration and DEA and everybody comes
down on me this I'm going into Canada
now oh we're going back home and so so
they uh they they said uh Mr Tron do you
have any more
marijuana you know they got the pipe
uh make it easier on you if blah blah
blah you know that always be oh yeah I
got a lot of pot let me see and find it
for him
you got my passport and they
go in the back room you know trying to
figure out what charges are going to lay
on me you know
then they come back hand me my passport
and says
you can go
I says
what is well you were born in Canada so
we can't keep you out of Canada
and you have a United States passport so
we can't keep you out of the United
States
and so yeah you're free to go I said
that means I can smuggle pot back and
forth and then the guy really said oh
don't do that
it's the nicest thing please sir don't
smuggle weed please don't don't do that
how um how do you go back now to Canada
well because I haven't been back for
over a year you know because of the
restrictions yeah yeah it's crazy but no
I got no problem now you know in fact my
teaching that got together
we did our
um 08 you know a big reunion tour and it
was called get it legal tour that's when
you you guys that was on your break and
you came back and the oh it was the
comeback yeah that was a big long
stretch yeah it was a big comeback and
so we're together and we're going into
Canada for the first time we're going
into I think it was Hamilton
yeah or Toronto somewhere in there
anyway
we get to the Border in the Canadian
immigration are wearing flak jackets
why
because these famous Stoners are
invading their country oh my God
had their flight the only thing they
didn't have was their math their uh for
you guys yeah the mask
and it's Cheech and Chong and I get what
whipped through I'm a Canadian and she
just takes hours to get him through you
would think since they know who you are
like oh no they're here to play yeah
even you guys get messed with at the
border oh big time that makes me feel
better
oh man one time one time
I'm getting ready to leave uh on on the
gig and there's a a pen case where I
used to carry my joints a couple of
joints in it and I see that in my
luggage and so I take it out and I put
it on the dresser
zip up the bag
now we get to the Border and the guy
goes what's in the bag
and so nothing put it in take a look he
opens a bag and there's a pen case
my wife thought I had forgot it and she
slipped it back in the bag
and she said my face just drained I
looked at that and so he opened the pen
case and there's the joints sitting
there
and the guy picks up the joint oh
so right away he calls the superior you
know the sergeant or whatever and so now
we have to go in the guy's office and
the guy picks up the joint oh wow a
whole joint from Cheech and Chong oh wow
get up
yes smoke sweet get out of here uh can
we have the joint nah get out of here he
kept it no yeah he kept it but but he
let us go and then I think yeah it was
the same time we had a roadie Jimmy root
and he used to carry this purse at
jingle jangled you know he's a hippie
and we'd hear the jingle jangle the
plane we were on gets all of a sudden is
forced to land I think it was like
Spokane or something you know just a
real short short or was Idaho
and the pilot comes on we're making uh
unexpected landing and we have to land
don't worry folks uh everything's fine
the plane lands
feds get on the plane go back and they
grab our road a Jimmy root
and they yard him off the plane and that
purse is jingling and
Jimmy goes what's going on well what
they did what we found out later because
the plane kept going he's eroded he's a
roadie so he'll catch up with us later
and so we find out later that
because of Cheech and Chong we got
through it but they never checked out
the third guy
and so that he might be the guy that's
carrying all those or something or
whatever and Jimmy as clean as a whistle
you know oh God we laugh because both
teachers are sitting there and you go to
jail huh did he go to jail oh no no no
no they couldn't just searched him on
the plane they just play in that that
power trip you know I know they made you
laugh to show you guys don't [ __ ] no
I'm teaching her we're both Cold Blood I
don't know him you know is he your Rudy
no I never saw him you know
oh just let him go I mean you kind of
have to man well he's a Rhoda he's a
roadie that's what rodeos are for they
take directly for you you know they do
all the dirty work and then yeah and
Brody and take him like no he's fine oh
we we had we had a lot of fun
but
you know it never got serious ever you
know because we I we know that this part
is the the most it's a medicine
and now from that from that instance to
now how do you feel about that
legalization's coming yeah it's coming
soon Federal I know I feel it no it has
to how do you feel about that how has
that changed no I feel great but I also
I also tell people you know
just relax
you know because you're changing a
system think about it yes weed
as a black market product is the most
popular
Black Market product in history
in history yeah nothing has ever reached
the billions and the billions of dollars
Black Market money that's true uh El
Chapo everyone sells wheat El Chapo El
Chapo man he had
safe houses full of cash
and now and that cash you know where it
went a lot of it the DEA really the cops
second knocked off our taxes
you got 30 000. can you not that's why
they got DEA agents with two homes and
Yachts we were just talking about this
before you got here ATF think about that
Alcohol Tobacco firearm yeah three
deadly things
that [ __ ] crazy that weed's the only
one not on there it's illegal it's a TR
but Alcohol Tobacco Firearms are all
together yeah that doesn't make sense
because when they were illegal
the black market for the alcohol the
black market for cigarettes you know
these are stub substances like heroin
and like heroin if they legalized heroin
there would be no heroin problem
yeah people I think that we talked about
this I think in Mexico they're trying to
decriminalize what is it all drugs
correct and that stops the black market
money coming in so so much and that's
why a lot of people are dying
because you mess with their money oh
oh I didn't even think about it oh you
don't know you messed with their money
no you can be logical all you want
but the reason pot isn't legal now
is because of the black market
you know there's so many people I'm
talking about
billionaires people across the the board
because think about it with weed money
illegal weed money there's no taxes
all you have to do is find some business
to launder your money in Easy what you
can do because every every business you
know hotels
Condominiums yeah the building of that
three million laundromats like La go
down go down anywhere in like Koreatown
like it just says water it just says
clothes like those are fake
that's a laundry place yeah
and who's going to complain you know
because the tax guys they're clean
who's going to complain just like that
building that just fell down in and I
saw that that was sad
Florida you know
Building Inspections got paid off on
that oh to let it collapse I didn't even
think about that it's not land no or to
let the no way what it is is that they
used first of all they used inferior
building uh products there's a cement
that Marine cement
that will withstand
um salt water you see underneath Miami
salt water
and so salt water will Leach in uh in
ordinary cement because ordinary cement
is what sand and uh and uh you know uh
but you know that makes up from the
desert and Marine is a whole different
thing you know when they put in the
marinas and that you know they use a
whole different a different kind of
cement I didn't even know that and it's
very expensive and and so on I was there
with the chance so they just went cheap
see that's why and then I mean this is
my just my opinion and then the salt
water leeches in from the ocean because
underneath Miami is salt water you know
and then uh JP my my uh manager here he
he said that the same thing that the the
the hardware you know the Bedrock
underneath Miami is porous
so it's coming so it's so it sucks up
the water now when the tide goes out the
water leaches out and what happens when
you get sinkholes and that's why that
and that the combination of shoddy
construction and and sinkholes a lot
goes into that wow I didn't even think
about that and then they've been warned
you know oh they had been oh [ __ ] yeah
damn that's so sad you might just live
in your building falls I'd be so [ __ ]
pissed I can't look at it that way oh I
got my lighter here sorry no
if you're a long time listener you
already know manscaped has been down
with us since the very beginning so
shout out to them if you're a new
listener and you don't know what
manscaped is let me explain it to you in
our terms it's for your balls and dick
this is a male grooming
yo every time every time it's gonna be
hard to do these it makes me laugh okay
this is a line of male grooming products
they have every single thing as you can
see ball wipes to Shavers right here to
Cologne for your balls anything I feel
they're best known for is the lawnmower
and this is the 4.0 since about
1972 people started giving a [ __ ] so for
all you guys out there if you're looking
for a shaver grooming tool this I'm
gonna be honest from me to you out of
everything I've ever used this is the
safest honestly because we've all seen
the blood I've taught how many ads have
you done for manscape we've all seen a
little trickle blood in the shower and
we freak out and think it's going to be
terrible and our Ball's gonna fall out
or something great don't lie this is
skin safe guys this is rechargeable
wirelessly rechargeable it's waterproof
so you can have it in the shower you
don't have to hold all right well I'll
have to explain it you guys I don't have
to give you the picture let's stop and
it's also got a light on it guys you
cannot be a nasty ass fool when you have
a lawnmower for everyone interested in
the manscape products go to
www.manscape.com forward slash Yola it's
linked in all of our videos so if you
just go in the description below if
you're on Spotify YouTube no matter
where you're at the manscape is linked
right there it's forward slash Yola and
20 off and free shipping so right off
the bat if you just want to get
introduced to the manscape brand if you
just yeah maybe I'll try it out at least
use the user link 20 off free shipping
so as I said they have jails roll-on
stuff they have they have ball pipes
cologne lawnmower there's so much they
have underwear guys just check out
manscape.com as I said it's manscape.com
forward slash Yola 20 off free shipping
as always guys thank you for using the
code thank you for using the links and
supporting the sponsors that support our
podcast yes you're supporting our
podcast but for finances and stuff for
ad reads you guys you guys watching the
podcast this is how it works but we want
to bring you stuff that we think you're
gonna actually use we think you'll like
and so far the manscape code you guys
are doing thank you you guys guys you
guys are using the actual code it's
actually working you're using the links
manscapes lets us know so thank you guys
for supporting as always guys back to
the episode
I I'm kind of pragmatic in a way that
we're all gonna die
because we're we're not meant to be in a
physical Universe forever yes you know
but we are Eternal spirits
so we we've always been here in one form
or another
and so when you die I
your body dies or or you change like a
caterpillar you know it changes from a
caterpillar
it dies as a caterpillar but it emerges
as a butterfly
and then what does a butterfly do mate
lays eggs now you got another
caterpillar
and and that's a cycle of life and
that's the same as humans you know we're
only here for a relatively brief period
of time yeah you know compared to you
know the universe has been around for
like ever
billions of [ __ ] years no beyond that
and what is a year think about what a
year is we make that yeah a year is the
time it takes Earth to go around the Sun
that's it
there's no such thing as time like in
the spiritual world but in the physical
world nothing but time
see yes and that's the way that's
weighted because everything there for
every
in order to have up you have to have
down in order to have right you have to
have left in order to have cheats you
have to have charm you know that's the
way the order of things only in the
physical world
but in the in the spiritual world
there's nothing but love
think about that
last time I talked to you I probably
won't remember you said something to me
and I've literally used it my since the
last time I talked to you you told me
I know it's it's actually so simple but
I I'm honestly do I think about this all
the time you said
it's easy to be happy when you live in
the present it's easy to be sad when you
think about the past because you might
want to go back to the time you were
most happy it's sad to think about the
future of the future is something that
might be a little on the downward spiral
or maybe you're not in good health or
maybe this and you say if you live in
the present you can't be anything but
happy and I've used that as much as I
can when I start thinking about like all
right I got six months of this left okay
this much money today goes this okay
let's calm down this is what am I doing
I'm smoking a joint watching something
hilarious let's hang out let's hang out
and I'll deal with it sometimes I've
used it since I met you and that's
that's the way I look at at everything
and you know in the people that I talk
to you know I I I do cameos now and I
get a lot of cameos because
of of uh my Outlook and I got my Outlook
what from jazz music
yeah like I'm doing poetry now instead
of uh not instead of but I'm a better
poet than I am a songwriter because I
you know I only got a few Melodies that
I can use and it's always somebody
else's oh [ __ ]
sampling I was like oh yeah I know that
that song but
poetry
like I I use my phone and no matter
where I'm at like like I'll be driving
her anywhere I got a phone and I can
write and I'll I'll tap out a poem
and I've got so many and this morning
um or just before I came here I was
working out with my my son because what
I want to do now is my son's like a jazz
musician and so I I read a bunch of
poems to him and uh he's going to take
him and then put a drum track to it nice
little music to it and just uh just
because it's all
the problem I not a problem I appreciate
rap
in hip-hop
because of the rhythmic use of the
English voice
you know yeah but the words in there are
sometimes are so
incredible but
the music gives it a different tone you
know
so it's it's not like when you do a
movie and you want to show sadness you
write sad music or or danger you know
well some of that music when you think
about some of the songs if that you hear
the lyrics they're like so sad but
people
dance
but now my love now that it's over hey
how's your drink yeah you know what I
mean yeah it sounds like it could be
nonsense and you're still like yeah it's
just pop it's like pop that's what it
ended up being
La Band Boom Tutti Frutti Richards
that was the song the whole song was
that it's just scattered
[Music]
Daisy almost drive me crazy
the Golden Age and so what I realized
my poetry man the words
I want the word like what I told you you
know it resonates yes stays stays and so
the music I'm putting to my poetry now
compliments
it plays background see
and see where the words are really the
background to the music you know because
some of the lyrics When you listen to
them like
Joni Mitchell lyrics oh
oh
I was trying to get a man I always
trained to do him right
and same as the the Blues
I love you know what I love because of
the racism going around
when you when you look at it
like I've never been a big fan of the
Beach Boys me neither and the reason is
is that I can't relate to the lifestyle
that they were singing about yes you
know in my room you know now if we were
to do it to be in my room there was
Uncle Charlie and Uncle Auntie and
chatha and Billy and and the twins
in my room you know I was never a fan
and my room was my alcoholic aunt you
know that no one else would take in but
we would because she got a great pension
from the war
and she would she bought me my guitar
amp when I started playing guitar you
know I was so poor at one time I never
owned a guitar
when I would go to a gig
the guy I was working for would give me
a guitar his guitar he told me you grew
up without money you said you're
when you used to ride in the car you
remember seeing the floor through the
through the floorboards yeah that's
that's some Flintstones crazy [ __ ] right
there that was some of my earliest
memories oh yeah and I told you the
power of Prayer
because yeah oh when you wait for your
dad to get a job that's right that's
right that's right that's right because
I was going to Sunday school and they
said if you want something you got to
pray for it remember you did say that
and I thought wow
yeah and it worked my dad got a job and
I kind of keep score
you know I kept scoring the whole time
and and I listened I listened to the um
to the God you know the to the preaching
that I got because uh
oh
I mean it was so right on
and the thing that's why I'm quite sure
you know my whole life has been sort of
ordained you know I'm not just here
to be here yes I'm here to spread the
gospel you know
you know to get weed legal to be part of
it you know it's coming and and and
that's that's what I am you know it's
it's kind of like being a lightning rod
too you know you know the lightning rods
only purpose is
to get by hit by lightning
so is that someone else won't get hit by
like you know what I'm saying that's
true that's true you you guys have paved
paved away man yeah paved the way I mean
yeah you just said it yourself I think I
don't even know if we started yet we're
talking about Howard Stern
I mean the one of the biggest voices on
the planet and he sees what listen to
your records yeah listen to you so when
you when you started this if you could
put it together when you started this
you were doing this strip club and
thought I'm not an actor I'm gonna get
on stage and that moment you you realize
you loved it and just started going from
there made records then you made move
and then I mean look yeah well that's
when people say to me you know
how do you want to be remembered what
you know because I want to be remembered
as a guy that wasn't really anything
[Laughter]
like I wasn't really a guitar player I
wasn't really an actor was it really a
director or was it really a writer I
wasn't really all these things but I did
them
you know because that's the way that's
the way it is
because it's not me doing it that's the
key
it's not me doing it it's my spirit
when people say to people that oh you've
got a lot of spirit or that horse has
spirit
spirit's a good word
because it really says it all
you know yes
because spiritual spirit is something
that you can't buy
you can't rent
you can't teach is have it that's it
that's it
and if you got it
and then see see I was given the
combination when I was really young
the combination of okay
this is how you this is where you go
and it's all written as I actually
people have been chanting the truth for
years and had no idea what they were
saying
you know what it is The Lord's Prayer
Our Father Who Art in Heaven
right there right there
God's not here
God's in heaven Oh I thought you're
saying and you no God's in heaven okay
okay where's heaven
in the spirit world
so God is Spirit
okay Hallowed be thy name
now he's not only God
but he's so powerful or she
that just to mention his name
in a holy manner
gives you the power of the universe
that's how much power in the Hallowed be
thy name
God's name is hallowed it's so special
um but it also says you know don't use
that name in vain
you know so when people use God as a
curse word
that's not helping their cause too much
you know gotcha you know what I'm saying
I I did not grow up religious so that he
just broke it down very well to me
actually think about it yeah and then
Hallowed be thy name thy kingdom come
so the kingdom that we're in it belongs
to God
not ours we're beholders but we're very
important because God is a performer but
what does all performers need
an audience an audience
and there's no restrictions on audiences
you don't have to be talent to be an
audience sure you just have to be alive
and you're an audience you're a beholder
so
thy kingdom come thy King his kingdom
thy will be done
so whatever God wants done it will be
done there's no escaping it and if it
doesn't get done that means
God wasn't in it so that's why you said
it was written so if God is in it no
matter what God's in
it will get done
on Earth here as it is in heaven
that is the thing only God can because
he produced
uh the the physical world
but he's always been in the in the uh
spiritual world
and there is no beginning or no end in
the spiritual world but there's tons of
beginnings and ends in the physical
world in us as humans we're part of it
now when we come back
because we're here to learn okay so we
can come back as a later grass
I see what you're saying yes it's a
mouse we could come back as a rat we can
come back as a dog we can come back as a
whale
because we're all in the same spiritual
I mean physical world where we're
breathing the same error
drinking the same water
you know
it's compatible for human life
but
only if you follow the physical rules
yes if you break the physical rules then
you're out of here next next uh but
where are you going where are you going
you're going back into the spiritual
world
I also had a an epiphany about
evil
evil people
because
one of the religious books I read or
spiritual books I read you know said
that in heaven you'll meet a a Hitler a
Mussolini in heaven
yeah because there's no sin
in heaven
see there's no nothing but love
and so yeah you're going to meet these
guys you might recognize them yes you
won't recognize them but they'll be
there
now they were here to do evil because to
learn which we all will be doing because
eternity means we have enough time
to be evil and to be good and to be
there to be straight to be black to be
white to be ground it's the second time
I've heard someone explain this to me
this exact way we all come back to play
every role so we can experience and we
will play every role I've heard that
before that's crazy people who said that
because we're not going to go anywhere
because we're stuck in eternity is the
loop we will always be here
in one form or another
so I can a picture me being a a
meteorite circling around the earth for
until I bump into something else and
become something else and then that can
bump into something and become something
or nothing for another Millennium or
zillion or whatever and then all of a
sudden that nothing becomes something
I mean
when you
are blessed like I I've been obviously
been blessed
it's
it's beyond
like I'm beyond Joy or you know
it's
because when you know these things then
what makes like what makes me happy
my wife
who I still get jealous over
that's good man that's still alive for
83 years old and I still get Jealous
not still
I am a jealous guy and she knows it
and uh
oh and we've created the most beautiful
family
is so beautiful and they're all
different you know like my son married
an Indonesian lady her his daughter his
daughter goes to Arabic school they're
Muslims
she studies the Quran
and that's her daughter that's my
granddaughter
and then we got a little the brand new
baby grand baby a little Akira oh she
she's so beautiful she loves me
whenever she sees me she smiles and
she'd be making strange with everybody
else and she sees Grandpa
big smile and she sleeps on my chest
she just wants to snuggle and sleep
I've got and they're all staying with me
now you know they're all at the house
well not my son no Paris in them and
they got their own house and that but my
life
it couldn't be more beautiful
seriously couldn't be so good to hear
man yeah I'm hanging with billionaires
and you know I'm staying out there how
they're second home yeah
their second home not even their first
home they got places in the Hamptons
they got you know they're they're
multi-billionaires you know
and yet
I signed way more autographs than they
do
he spreads I feel like it's the give and
take you gave so much happiness to
people that you can't you're Overjoyed
if there was a word past that that's you
you wake up knowing like no I'm doing
everything I've ever wanted with who I
want and I'm happy yeah that's the best
thing
like I told you about living in the
present you know yes I mean my life in
the present no no the worst thing that
happened to me was today all of a sudden
I got blindsided with uh uh my Tick Tock
uh photographers shows up I look at him
it's not Sunday next thing you know he
brings in a big green screen and a whole
shitload of clothes and and and then a
couple of strangers walk in carrying a
dab outfits oh you weren't ready for
that one
well you know the way I am I said they
probably told me and I didn't remember
yeah enough right
fine cause because what are you what are
you gonna do complain no he can't what
are you gonna do you're gonna do it
whatever they want to get done and I did
it
and uh
I'm still but they know you know the
universe is so beautiful with me I mean
you could you know just by what I've
done you know so the people around me
they're they're so
tuned in to who I am and what I am and
what I like and what I won't do and you
know that kind of thing there's very few
things that I won't do you know but
there's a very thing you know like when
I'm with cheats sometimes because she
just because he's kind of getting a
little grumpy
and when we're shooting the rest of that
uh
um the documentary that we're going to
be out there
the the director wanted some some
uh conflict you know every every good
play has conflict yeah
and so he managed to piss both cheechoff
and my wife
the director yeah and so he got conflict
are you guys done with the documentary
yeah it's all done when does that come
out probably a couple of months far as I
know I don't know because he's been
working on five years so oh wow so it
could be any time now but there's no
time limit man no such thing as a
deadline there's just opening night
and closing night that's all that
matters then with everything in between
um I know uh we got to get you out of
here I know you have to do more they
said
um before you go
I know uh I really appreciate this
hopefully it's not the last time I know
I have so many questions I wanted to ask
but I know you're on a time limit but
before you go ask him whatever you want
man okay I got one more question answers
all right I'll give you I'll do one more
question
um you told me about it last time but I
want the audience to hear
you
pretty much right there it's uh from
being in the success of Cheech and Chong
the success of all your stuff your your
music the shows and then you land the
spot on 70s Show Leo I mean such a
such a perfect character I mean even as
a kid I want that's John Cheech and
Chong right from the set like it was
such a perfect character you were on
them for so long it's such a good show
do you like doing movies better and
especially if you don't have to do you
like doing movies or or TV better
especially when you don't have to be the
director you don't have to be go here go
here go here you just walk up do your
thing and you leave what did you like
better having full control of the entire
process I like both equal yeah okay
equal it was an experience
total oh yeah great experience now at
first it was a little strange being on
the 70s Show because you had to read
exactly what they had you know yeah
and and the thing I liked about it is
there I never had a lot of lines
you know I love that yeah I guess that
is true huh I didn't think about it no I
didn't have very many lines I think just
standing there and so I would but it was
what it was they wanted that that life
force
of that character in there and see
because that that life force
validated that life that time of uh that
period perfect that time period it was
perfect because it was a life force of a
guy trying to make it in a photo booth
you know in the record store all this
crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
and and because the character it was the
way he was you didn't have to get him
high you know that that's him that was
him it's permanent and I did a bit Yeah
so so that 70 show really
again you know I'm a blessed person man
I'm very blessed because it was like
that show was written for me 100 that
was a perfect part yeah that was the
part yeah yes and and then when I left
when I was gone for a year you know I
guess things started
dropping and then boom was that why they
wrote you off because you had to go to
jail yeah is that why yeah I thought I
was like all right he's done being
Hyde's dad basically I thought that was
just no no part of the episode but you
know you know what happened what
happened was that I asked for a raise
Oh I thought I should be getting more
because they knew the value of my value
to that show and so then I'm just there
was no bump in the salary you know it
stayed the same stated that every year
stayed the same and then finally I don't
really give a [ __ ] you know I never did
but but I said I better ask for a raise
so they wrote me out and then I got
busted perfect timing
again Serendipity man perfect time
Serendipity and then when I got out they
wrote me back in
yeah you came back for one episode right
then I came back with the last one the
last yeah I remember that no I did the
whole year I don't I just remember the
last episode was Seth Meyers on there I
don't remember that season as much when
Eric was gone and Kelso was gone
everybody was gone it was they were
getting ready to and then you understand
it anyway and when I came back was
perfect way to end it that's a great
last episode that's one of my favorite
last episodes of a series ending it was
just so it was I love what happened
after him I love the fact that Jackie
and Kelso
I know now they're actually their
Council got married in real life because
they grew up together they fell in love
with each other what a what a story what
a story beautiful story and to see it of
course Ashton tried to go Hollywood you
know Demi Moore for a while and he was
trying his best and then and and uh Mia
she started becoming those award-winning
actress
whoa you know what am I looking over
here when it's right in front of my face
the whole time yeah that's a great what
a great story I didn't even think about
to bring that up yeah what a full circle
yeah they actually got together yeah it
went a great story and and the other
ones they all got stories Danny in
trouble you know but yeah I see all that
was uh with the ladies you know and then
everyone no Wilmer
I I try to hook up with Wilmer kind of
you know but wilmer's Boomer you know
he's
he's you know he's got his thing going
everybody's got something going on I
love that yeah that was the old 70s Show
what other question
um we'll do one more because I know
they're they want they want to wrap it
up I got one more
uh for everyone else we talked about it
last time I was such a big fan of Half
Baked I brought this up to you and then
you told me the story so I want I kind
of just I know a quick brief story about
this
your Squirrel Master obviously in Half
Baked you're gonna beat the [ __ ] out of
everybody and then when you went to jail
and I asked did anybody call You
Squirrel Master in there and then you
told me you were feeding a group of
squirrels I ended up being a squirrel
Master anyway when you went to jail for
real
name chubs right you're such a big guy
the big guy yeah what was the chubby was
it chubby yeah yeah you said you started
feeding a group of squirrels while in
prison yeah the the mess hall the food
was so bad that even the squirrels got
fat because it was just all carbs and so
the squirrels would ground squirrels
would get so fat they couldn't get back
in their hole I can't believe what are
the odds of that and the Hawks would sit
up on the late that's right be looking
up there waiting for the right one to
get fat no and that's what he did the
heart went down grabbed the fatty they
couldn't get in the in the thing and he
brought him up to the late
fixture was hundreds of feet in the air
and and the mechanics that I was hanging
with at the time you know the
electricians they're up there and they
were telling us all that they found uh
the the ground squirrel up there Patty
chubby whatever his name was up in the
in the light fixture in the nest in the
being eaten and and the one guy when one
of the prisoners says you know ain't no
way that ground squirrel crawled up that
pipe he thought that was real
100 feet in the air ain't no way the
backgrounds grow crawled up that plate
I we laughed so hard at that I just
think it's
what a full circle
you play the exact character you ended
up being in jail what was that about
what was that with Dave Chappelle what
are the odds that's Dave ship power
I'm telling you and Dave Dave is another
truth teller you know he's going around
town doing the best comedy ever ever
what up whatever a genius we're lucky to
see it you had to see a lot of good a
lot of good comedians too from the start
of their careers too
and the ones that admire you know I
really admire like uh Steve Martin you
know really love Steve Martin because
I'm a musician and he really is a
musicians I've only seen one one when I
was a kid and he's got the not a bowl
cut but like if my hair was down you got
that and he's talking he's like he's got
a banjo yeah I think he's got a suit I
can't remember I watched it with my mom
but it was just [ __ ] hysterical oh no
he's he his movies and everything now oh
he's another apparently his Inspector
Clouseau you know because I was really
good friends with Peter seller so I
never really got to see uh Steve
Martin's version of The Pink Panther
but I'm going to Rand it or check the
house I got to see it I gotta see it
because I know and and uh who's the guy
that got uh
uh Louis CK funny as hell
funny oh he was my uh
I you know I discovered him after Cheech
and I you know got back together you
know then I discovered Louis CK
no I discovered him before when when
Shelby and I were doing my wife and I
were doing comedy just the two of us and
we went and saw Lewis and and in fact
oh no we're with each because I was
telling Lewis that my wife and I used to
work and then now she opens for us with
the Cheech and Chong show
and uh and Louis was telling me and he
gave me the idea to introduce her myself
don't let emcee introduce Shelby because
then it really puts her off on a bad
footing but if I introduce her then the
crowd's going to accept her right away
because they hear my voice and it's
respect
or you know
yeah I'd love to are there so many good
comedians out man fluffy yeah he's
hilarious we're just talking about him
recently I want to hear Fluffy's uh rap
with the other fat boys that he hangs
with I haven't seen it I haven't watched
it I've only seen it no
it's it's just his crew oh just his
friends
I want to hear their dinner Prime plans
oh [ __ ] it must be extravagant
yeah because you get in that world man
yeah start making money Chinese food has
a whole different meaning to those guys
they're probably going to the most
places we never heard of oh and and you
can get this portion in that portion
yeah
um well I want to say thank you so much
for coming I know we got to wrap up okay
we'll be wrapping up yeah there or you
know have we been rolling
[Laughter]
yeah
we started already
what time is it
it's been an hour and a half already oh
[ __ ] I gotta go I gotta go meet this guy
and do his TV show there it is or is
that you
it's that's the weed that's the weed
talking that's good weed by the way it
is is this mine that's yours yeah Tommy
Chong so cheap uh Chong's Choice it's
Chong choice no it's Tommy Chong's weed
it's called Tommy Chong sweet yeah
that's why one of the that was my last
question is that what it was it it is
now
[Laughter]
a little slow in the uptake but he's a
good liar
that's a good one I told you in Aspen I
got lost couldn't find the head shop and
I was in between two of them one one
here I'm done there and I'm looking
around work yeah
apparently the guy the guy saw me and he
took me over well let's try this one and
wasn't it and went downstairs and we
found the one he bought me a Tommy Chong
bud
all for the weed yeah nice yeah very
you're in you're in Colorado California
yeah right is it any other states oh
we're not a shitload of places so it's
just we're in uh Massachusetts and we're
in um
Detroit Michigan we're in Michigan
Chicago all the recreational we're all
over the world
cannabis right that's what it's called
oh thank you not no offense but they're
breath mints
uh no no really seriously no they're
they really are yes yeah yeah
wow look at that yeah that will melt in
your mouth
and it melts your brain a bit too
if THC infused breath strips yeah that's
what they are
that's awesome so you want to give your
boy some and uh Tommy Chong or you're
just going to keep it all to yourself
we'll go hard and do the whole pack
thank you so much so this is uh uh Tommy
Chong's canvas so that's where everybody
can find it right yeah all right and
it's available it's going to be
available everywhere nice and uh it's uh
it's going to be uh
yeah we're gonna rule the world
eventually you know it's the attitude
yeah
especially when everybody else messes it
up so bad you know what I mean yeah
because I I love shopping in thrift
stores that's that's my favorite store
to go to a thrift store
because you get a little history of
where you're at you know and then you
find objects that you can't find
anywhere because you're one of a kind
that's true little carvings little stuff
you know so so a thrift store to me like
when I was a kid you know I used to walk
home by the through the alleys and see
what people threw out then if I found
something that you know I could use I'd
take it you know and other things I just
look at it and leave it but I like
thrift stores because if for some reason
you don't like what you bought
you give it back to him I guess so right
that's all I used to go to a little
antique shops too when I was younger
yeah it's just fun man and I love the
people you meet there too
you know there's always a weird owner
but he's nice it's just a little weird
yeah or or a bunch of old ladies you
know working for you know a charity you
know that's true that's true
well I'm gonna have to have three
dollars for that
yeah we're gonna have to have three
dollars for that sir
this is not straight it's not a sound of
like a train went by
is that a train yeah
it always scares the [ __ ] where the hell
are we
are we we're in Burbank
Burbank the yellow trains here now they
do apparently right when we're [ __ ]
filming
um so Tommy Chong's cannabis so
everybody could find that
um
thank you so we sell the best CBD
products and that's legal everywhere oh
man everywhere yeah uh Tommy Chong with
canvas.com is what I'm assuming uh yeah
get
anyway look it up look at that it's on
the Internet it's got Tommy Chong yeah
yeah Google yeah okay well maybe next uh
we'll do another one of these I have
a stack of questions but we'll save it
for next time I know you're on a time
limit okay thank you so much
I really appreciate it that's everything
who gives me the check where's it right
over there
oh you're the designated payer I push
buttons over here
well thank you so much I appreciate it
okay all right thank you guys that was
Tommy Chong thank you for stopping by I
hope you have a good day
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]